[Musik]
jetzt ja alle miteinander feiern wir das
oktoberfest ein seit gestern ist das
oktoberfest bohrer
ja da bin ich auch richtig scharf drauf
ja wir waren selber noch nie dort
ich habe mir gerade in österreich sind
enten gekauft heute backen wir ein
drittel
nächste woche hat gibt viele doris
worden wo ich habe keine lösung aber
einfach kommt noch eine erwartet nur
noch nicht ganz sicher nicht jeden war
und nur zum essen wahrscheinlich
jedenfalls habe ich heute einen
motivator für euch und zwar ist es diese
hier tarantel gebacken
im inneren steckt eine richtig leckere
torte und zwar habe ich eine mandel
zitronen torte mit einer weißen ganache
und marillenmarmelade und überzogen und
dekoriert mit von dong und mit bisschen
modellierte rollator als muss auch nicht
immer ohne dirndl seines kann auch mit
kleinen leuten aus und das brautkleid
machen dass wir haben es sehr sehr
dezent gehalten doppel d stets schwarze
im okt es hat auch sehr viel spaß
gemacht dass ich ihre arbeit zu leisten
und ja die torte ist gar nicht so
schwierig ich habe heute morgen damit
angefangen habe acht stunden dafür
gebraucht und ich wollte eigentlich um
die ampel backen aber dass dem so war zu
teuer okay
das heißt nicht schmutzig machen auf
jeden fall könnte diese doppel zum
beispiel auf fischmarkt wo ihn ja wir
könnten jungdesigner abschied machen zb
ja zb und was hat es eigentlich kostet
sage ich dir nicht weil es diese kassen
wenig darja kanada wurde dachte ich das
wäre die artikelnummer aber es war dann
der preis ja wir waren nämlich neulich
in salzburg in österreich und dann hat
uns die juli exakt wenn ich komme jetzt
tolle tieren sind und dann habe ich mir
ein schönes tier und so ausgesucht genau
und gleich gepackt und genau und ich
habe direkt mir lieber an die indische
organ mafia vertrauen und daher mussten
gleich geholt oder und es war jedenfalls
reden wir da nicht mehr drüber
ich zeige euch jetzt nämlich wie man die
torte herrschte zuerst einmal muss man
den teig zubereiten und hier vorne sehr
die zutaten für den teig brauch ich
sechs eier etwas von den extrakt eine
prise salz 300 gramm zucker jeweils 300
milliliter buttermilch und
sonnenblumenöl 450 gramm mehl 200 kann
die habe ich bereits fein gemahlen ein
päckchen backpulver und den abrieb einer
unbehandelten zitrone
jetzt gebe ich zuerst einmal die eier in
die rührschüssel da kommen jetzt vanille
extrakt um salz rein und auch der zucker
und die masse werde vier bis fünf
minuten cremig verrührt
[Musik]
die masse verrührt die zitronenschale
habe ich bereits abgegeben
jetzt kommt die mit dazu und auch die
buttermilch und das öl und die zutaten
werden kurz eingeführt
[Musik]
hier fahre ich jetzt die trockenen
zutaten also backpulver mail und die
gemahlenen mandeln und die ruhe ich dann
ganz kurz in den teig 1
[Musik]
den teig fühle ich jetzt immer in der
backform ein da habe ich jetzt eine herz
backform falls sie keine herzberg form
habt könnt ihr das ganze auch in dem
backblech backen oder mit dem bug rahmen
zum beispiel und später einfach
entsprechend zu schneiden so der
komplette teig da passt hier nicht rein
arbeit brauche auch noch ein bisschen
extra teig das heißt hier die form jetzt
zu drei viertel etwa führen und den
übrigen teig fühle ich dann in meinem
back ring den ich auf 20 cm eingestellt
habe
[Musik]
den teig sich jetzt hier am rand hoch
und zwar backt dadurch steigt auch ein
bisschen gleichmäßiger hoch
[Musik]
und so kommt da jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze und er braucht dann so etwa
40 bis 50 minuten ist auf jeden fall die
stäbchen probe machen und könnte den
anderen teig dann einfach anschließend
backen und der braucht etwa nur 20
minuten
die taten würden sie jetzt abgekühlt
aber das ganze ein bisschen schneller
geht habe ich sie einfach auf akkupacks
gesetzt und jetzt kann ich die backform
lösen
[Musik]
und jetzt stelle ich für die füllung
eine weiße ganache aus 300 gramm sahne
und 900 gramm weißer schokolade her
dafür lasse ich jetzt die saale in einem
topf aufkochen und zieht sie dann wieder
vom härter runter jetzt kann ich die
weiße schokolade einrühren und so lange
rühren bis keine klümpchen mehr
vorhanden sind
[Musik]
die kanalstrecke ich darf und dass sie
einfach bei zimmertemperatur abkühlen so
dass sie schön streichfähig wird jetzt
habe ich alles vorbereitet und jetzt
kann die torte gefüllt und
zusammengebaut werden
jetzt habe ich hier das herz das herz
werde ich jetzt gleich zweimal
durchschneiden mit motorsäge und hier
habe ich hat den übrigen teig und daraus
werden dann die brüste geformt zum
formen nehme ich jetzt einfach hier
diesen kessel und zwar nehme ich hatte
ihnen immer zum schokolade schmelzen und
von der größe her passt es hier ganz gut
und damit werde ich jetzt die brust
formen haben damit die post ihr licht
anklebt lege ich ein bisschen wie
frischhaltefolie rein
[Musik]
also das herz kommt kurz zur seite darum
kümmere ich mich gleich erst wenn die
brust oder dafür schneide ich jetzt den
teig hirten
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt einen tort bringen
dessen bisschen größer als die form da
kann auch ruhig ein bisschen größer sein
können aber zum beispiel auch einen
teller nehmen oder das ganze einfach ein
bisschen kleiner schneiden damit steche
ich das jetzt aus und kann jetzt diese
dünne teig scheibe hier hinein legen
ganz vorsichtig wenn sie reist ist aber
auch nicht schlimm denn da kommt ja
später noch keine strom- und diese
kuppel form wird gefüllt mit der garage
und auch mit etwas marmelade
da nehme ich jetzt marille vanille und
zwar ist es eine selbst gemachte
marmelade vom die die mayr aus
österreich
den haben wir neulich besucht und da
habe ich mir auch das band und gekauft
und von daher passt die marmelade hier
ganz gut rein
die die ich hoffe dort nichts dagegen
dass ich jetzt deine marmelade zum
füllen dieser brüste nehme aber auf
jeden fall wird es eine sehr leckere
torte und dann könnt ihr jetzt einfach
die ganzen tag reste mit reingeben ein
bisschen gaga schreien geben und das
ganze dann einfach gerade abschließen
[Musik]
zum abschluss gebe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen ganache drauf damit das ganze
schön gerade wird und jetzt kann ich die
folie darüber schlagen damit auch schön
glatt wird und jetzt stelle ich die
brust auf einen torten retter und frier
sie einfach für etwa eine halbe stunde
ein und in der zeit kann ich jetzt auch
diesen tortenboden durchschneiden und
dann auch die zweite brust erstellen
[Musik]
jetzt fühle ich die herzform und zwar
kommt jetzt auch ein bisschen von der
marmelade mit rein bisschen garage und
so setzt sich die komplette torte
zusammen
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt gefüllt und die
stelle ich jetzt ins gefrierfach für
etwa eine halbe stunde damit sie schön
fest wird und danach kann ich es zu
schneiden
in der zeit werden auch die brüste fest
und dann geht es mit der torte weiter
die torte weiz in der kühle und ist
jetzt schon fest und jetzt kann ich sie
bereits auf das skateboard draufsetzen
da werde ich später nämlich die torte
drauf servieren
der passt doch perfekt aber natürlich
musste vorher mit gallasch eingestrichen
werden
[Musik]
jetzt schneide ich hier unten die spitze
weg und setzt sie einfach hier oben rein
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich die torte einfach so ein
bisschen abrunden an den seiten so dass
es wirklich ein bisschen dreidimensional
auch aussieht
[Musik]
die turtles 30 jetzt ganz schön mit der
gerner schein und dann kann ich auch
gleich die zwei brüste draufsetzen
[Musik]
und jetzt werden die auch ein bisschen
bestrichen
das heißt zuerst einmal kommt die krümel
schicht um den ganzen kuchen krümmel zu
binden
dann stelle ich die torte noch einmal
kürbissen fest ist und dann wird sehr
schön glatt gestrichen
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann mit eurer chirurgischen
arbeit zufrieden seid könnt ihr die
torte kühl stellen und in der
zwischenzeit schon 750 gramm weist von
dann weiß kneten
ich habe jetzt hier 750 gramm bio von
dann bereits weiß geknetet und beim bier
von dort müsst ihr beachten dass am
anfang wirklich sehr hat aber durch das
kneten wieder weicher und die ganzen
zutaten für den von uns sind eben aus
ökologischer landwirtschaft und so alles
bio und falls euch davon dann aber zu
fest ist könnt ihr ihn auch für vier bis
fünf sekunden einfach in der mikrowelle
reingeben bei 800 grad
und dann wird ein bisschen wärme und
eben auch weiter
[Musik]
jetzt verspricht die torte mit etwas
faktoren spray damit davon dann gut dran
haftet und kann jetzt die decke drüber
legen und schön glatt streichen und bei
dem von don ist das gute des ein
bisschen elastischer das heißt den kann
man auch ein bisschen in form sehen und
auch wirklich schön dünn darüber legen
die reste schneide ich dann mit einem
messer weg und wenn ihr da jetzt mal
eine kleine macke mit drin habt ist das
gar nicht schlimm denn die wird dann
später überdeckt
[Musik]
ich habe ich mir jetzt ein kleines stück
vom band hautfarben gefärbt und zwar mit
etwas rot gelb und schwarz und dann
nehmt ihr einfach immer ganz ganz wenig
wie sie den gewünschten farbton habt
also sandkiste soll ich hab ich aber
sagen sie und bayerischer ton passt ganz
gut zu dem tempel eigentlich eher an
nordzone hannover oder hamburg man darf
nicht so viel sonne wie bei uns
habe ich hier die torte und jetzt
brauche ich nicht die komplette torte
mit dem von dort über zehn sondern ich
brauche im prinzip nur einen teil der
hier so rüber geht der rest wird nämlich
dann mit deko mit der bordüre und mit
der bluse sowieso überdeckt das heißt
ich leg das jetzt hier einmal drüber
dass es kurz an
[Musik]
und schneidet dann mit dem cuttermesser
ganz vorsichtig weg und web dann die
hautschicht sozusagen die
hauttransplantation mit esswaren kleber
ankleben
[Musik]
und ihr könnt jetzt damit die ränder
nicht so kantig sind einfach mit dem
finger darüber streichen
um das ganze so ein bisschen dünner und
flacher zu machen
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit der begleitung und da
müsst euch jetzt vorstellen sowie ihr
das dirndl auch anziehen würde
so muss auch die torte angezogen werden
das heißt zuerst die weiße bluse und
daneben das dirndl drüber also habe ich
jetzt hier weißen von dort genommen und
ein bisschen 20 verein geknetet ihr
könnt aber zum beispiel auch bisschen
blüten passte ein kneten und so wird er
nämlich später ein bisschen fester
das habe ich hier einen runden
ausstecher ihr könnt aber auch zum
beispiel einen teller nehmen oder ein
großes anderes gefäß dann einmal kurz
dran legen ob das so passt also ein
bisschen pro stand satz darf man sehen
nicht so viel
erst mal drauf legen auch nicht so weit
zusammen denn gleich kommt noch das
schwitzen muss da drauf und ein bisschen
dekolletee muss sein buch hat ganz ganz
wenig wir wollen so nicht zu übertreiben
es nicht so so werde ich das jetzt
ankleben schneit habe ich hier entlang
der haut auch dann weg
[Musik]
den restlichen von dort habe ich jetzt
sehr dünn ausgerollt und jetzt habe ich
hier soll und bordüren ausstecher und
kam das ganze jetzt hier ausstechen und
hier unten gerade abschneiden
und damit die bordüre ein bisschen
filigraner wird werde ich sitz hier mit
einem bord holen ein bisschen ausfüllen
das heißt immer hier am rand ganz kurz
entlang streichen und dann wirst du noch
und war eine richtige spitze haben
möchte nimmt jetzt hier noch zwei wochen
das ist jetzt zwei ganz kleine einmal
ein bisschen größer etwa zwei millimeter
durchmesser und 1 x 1 mm durchmesser und
da kommt jetzt noch ein paar löcher rein
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich noch hier rechts und auch
links noch jeweils eine spitze ankleben
ich habe zehn rote modell ihre
schokolade weiß geknetet und schön
ausgerollt und jetzt wird das dirndl
gemacht jetzt kommt der lustige party
ich werde jetzt hier zuerst einmal den
unteren teil machen und die arme
anschließend setzen
das heißt dieser modelle schokolade wird
das tier so daran geklebt und hier oben
schneide ich dann diese überreste weg
und nehme auch den mittelteil heraus
denn der wird grün
und dann brauche ich jetzt nicht noch
mal eine dritte schicht draufkleben
sondern kann hier einfach rot durch
grüne setzen
[Musik]
hier kommt jetzt auch eine grüne bordüre
hin dafür habe ich jetzt eine andere
borgia ausgesucht und die wird jetzt
auch ausgestochen und einfach angeklebt
[Musik]
jetzt ist noch der schulterbereich haben
dafür streiche ich jetzt hier ein
bisschen kleber wieder dran
und jetzt habe ich ein stück rote modell
er schokolade schon grob zugeschnitten
das setze jetzt hier am rand an also am
weißen rand dass hier alles schön sauber
zu ist und der rest wird am sauber
abgeschnitten und mit den fingern
angepasst
[Musik]
die torte habe ich jetzt kurz kühl
gestellt und jetzt stelle ich noch die
knöpfe für das dirndl her und dafür
könnt ihr entweder modelle schokolade
nehmen oder schwarze blüten passte ich
habe schwarze blüten pasta genommen und
eine silikonform die habe ich mit becker
stärke ausgekleidet und dann immer
kleine stückchen einfach hineingedrückt
die last die dann kurz antrocknen und
könnte dann schön heraus stützen
die das jetzt kurz antrocknen und werde
dann mit goldener pulver fahre ein
bisschen bepinseln
[Musik]
und hier habe ich noch ein paar sehr
blümchen hergestellt dafür habe ich
diesen kleinen auszeit genommen mit
dieser stempel funktion
dadurch bekommt man nämlich diese schöne
hunde form hin und in die mieter habe
ich dann einfach eine goldene perle
geklebt das skateboard werde es
überzogen und zwar vermisse ich den von
dann leicht marmoriert rolle in thun aus
und überzieht an das skateboard damit
[Musik]
und auf das skateboard klebe ich dann
noch buchstaben die ich vorher aus
modelle schokolade ausgestopft habe
[Musik]
das team zum markiere ich jetzt noch mit
einem präparat mit feinen ziernähten
jetzt kann ich noch die knöpfe an leben
und werde dann weißen von und weich
kneten und mit meiner von don presse
auspressen und klebe die kordel noch
zwischen die knöpfe
[Musik]
so sieht die tat jetzt aus jetzt sitze
angeschnitten
ich schneide ich einfach mal an der
höchsten stelle durch aha und schon
gespannt ist noch eine scheibe
durch auch nicht ganz so einfach zu
schön zu schneiden
[Musik]
der papst eintraf druck ich weiß gar
nicht entstehen zu den anfang
so kannst du staub bist genau hier sieht
man das innere die torte ist so
verschafft ich ja man sieht sie ist
richtig schön dass sie keine papiere und
das macht die marillen mario fillinger
noch nie gemacht
er halte die kurse von der österreich
sagt nein und ich weiß in afrika wille
da kann schon mal erzählen wieder die
marmelade schmeckt ja mal beim titel
geholt habe gebiete diese diesen becker
ja weiß ich wie die wie es bruder heißt
nein du den ich freue mich diesen lauf
ich will mir wieder in salzburg sind es
auch so lustig das wird so - und lag
richtig gut auf jeden fall zu empfehlen
ist ein motiv toppen und leben schmecken
ganz ehrlich ja da werden deutlich
begeistert sein und für nächste woche
habe ich mir überlegt machen wir eine
lederhose und da werde ich denke ich nur
als mittel haselnuss machen schokolade
passt dann auch perfekt zu der farbe
falls euch die torte gefallen hat könnt
ihr das genaue rezept nochmal nachlesen
auch six pack de
und ja ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen freue mich aufs nächste
mal
und nächste woche habe ich halt leider
keine lederhose dann stehe ich
wahrscheinlich mit der nächste schritt
ich finds auch vor leckere ich bin ich
ehrlich sein also ja schon ich sonst
nicht ich bin raus durchschnittlich gut
schmeckt und was macht es gleich wieder
gut das system dieser teuer war nächsten
mal schon gehalten
[Musik]